Borderline personality disorder is a serious mental illness, and it's
categorized by unstable moods, thoughts and behaviors. People with this
disorder have difficulty regulating their emotions and thoughts. They engage in
impulsive and reckless behavior, and they have difficulty maintaining
relationships with other individuals. In addition, people with this disorder
have out of control emotions, they're afraid of being abandoned, and they
vacillate between idolizing and despising those who are close to them. People
with this disorder are more likely to experience self-injury, such as cutting
themselves, burning themselves, or even attempting suicide. Moreover, they're
more likely to experience substance abuse, eating disorders, or anxiety
disorders. Interestingly, cultural factors or social factors may increase the
risk of this disorder. For example, living in a community or culture that has
unstable family relationships could increase the risk of borderline personality
disorder.